Adam let me start with the best opening
right now in the NFL was where did I
think you go to Indianapolis and start
there because if you operate with the
assumption that Andrew Luck is going to
get well and I believe you will then you
get Andrew Luck as a quarterback and get
Chris Fowler as a GM and to me that's
awfully attractive now I know the Giants
are a stable market and after going
through the instability that they have
you would think that the next coach
there should and would get an extended
run you have the second overall pick in
the draft but I like to look at these
things in the sense that you're also a
division with Carson Wentz for the next
dozen years dak Prescott for the next
dozen years it's a tough situation and
so I think indi appeals to me a little
bit more if you like Victor too risky
Chicago is a nice job but that's
dependent upon your taste in Germany Dan
it just really comes back to the
quarterback a butch quarterback do you
think is the best quarterback of all the
teams that have openings and there's
your answer
yeah but the Lions have the best
quarterback well then Detroit's a great
spot but do you think how much of this
with Gruden was he'd rather coach Derek
Carr than he would Jameis Winston listen
I think that there's been a dance there
that's gone on where Mark Davis has made
attempts to go get John in the past and
I think that John just got to a point in
his life after nine years of
broadcasting that it just became
something that he wanted to get back to
at some point the itch would not go away
and you have a situation there where he
does like Derek Carr quite a bit and he
wouldn't have taken a job unless he
believed in a quarterback I don't think
he chose there a car over Jameis Winston
I think that Oakland just made such a
strong push that Tampa Bay wasn't even
in it in that sense I mean it they
started dancing
they got serious they got engaged and if
Tampa was ever going to come out to the
scene John Orr and a ring on his finger
well give me an idea of are we looking
at ten million dollars a year
and part ownership here with the Raiders
for Gruden dam when it comes in I will
just say that the total value of the
deal will be the richest deal than any
coach s by a landslide now I don't know
that the ownership stake thing is going
to come through that have been discussed
there two three years ago
my sense is it's not gonna happen that's
my sense system but I do think that it's
going to be a lengthy contract very
lucrative and look I just think that
they made it such that he couldn't say
no and that's what you got so whatever
kind of contract we could conjure up in
our own minds or what that would be
something that you can't say in order
that's what it's gonna look like what's
the situation with marvin lewis i we
have six openings now how many more
openings are we gonna have well you know
here's the thing
Cincinnati's open rather Louis's
contract is up right okay but it's the
Bengals though it's the Bengals and they
can always bring him back yeah I got it
I got it it's it's a situation where
he's talking with Mike Brown right now
and and they're trying to see if there's
something that could be salvaged you
know the plan I think was for him to
move on I think there are people in the
organization that there have been issues
with but I think that they're trying to
see if there if this could be salvaged
and and they don't move to rush through
these decisions and again Mormons
contracts up so you know it's
interesting to me because when we're
bringing up all the great
assistant-coaching candidates out there
who are being contacted Matt Patricia
Josh McDaniels Steve Wilkes Chris
Rashard nobody has brought up Marvin
Lewis who technically is allowed to
contact it and I have a sense that some
of that is going on so we'll see how
again I think when you talk about the
candidates who are out there Marvin
Lewis his name should be included
because he's a free agent
right now now he may go back to
Cincinnati if they work it out and
figure it out that could happen but he's
freed in as of right now he's really not
the head coach of the Cincinnati Bengals
he's Adam Schefter he's covering the
Titans during the wild-card weekend on
Saturday for ESPN on ABC Lisa Salters
covering the Chiefs while Sean McDonough
and Jon Gruden will call the game
kickoff at 4:20 Eastern on the
mothership why is it the Patriots only
got what they got a second round pick
for Garoppolo well I think that's a
complicated question but basically
you've got a situation there where I
think ultimately in the end this was not
a negotiation this was not something
where the Patriots were back and forth
and said okay San Francisco if you don't
give us what we want then we are gonna
go to Cleveland which would have paid
whatever it took to go get Jimmy
Garoppolo look they were willing to give
up a two and a three for AJ McCarron
yeah what's Jimmy Garoppolo worth and I
think that they woke up that morning
that Monday morning the day before the
trade deadline on October 30th and made
the decision however they did that
they're gonna trade Jimmy Garoppolo and
I believe it was as simple as a simple
phone call to the Bay Area you want you
and Garoppolo yeah okay - - okay end of
contract negotiation or trade discussion
deal agreed - let's work it out let's
let the appropriate hmm people know so I
don't think it was something that they
wanted to do I think that it was
something that they felt like they had
to do and Jimmy grew up low to me is
already a top 10 quarterback one of the
best players in the league and with him
there in San Francisco the 49ers are set
for a long time and I think the Patriots
have questions long-term now without
Garoppolo in the fold yeah it feels like
Cleveland because when I was told
Cleveland was good
were offering more and they were gonna
offer first-round pick and then some and
that part of the arrangement was that he
was not going to be traded to Cleveland
you believe that I don't think this we I
do not believe this was a personal
vendetta Cleveland fired me I'm not
gonna trade my guy to Cleveland I do
think that the relationship and the
belief entrusted that Bill Belichick had
in John Lynch and Kyle Shanahan played a
part where when they know that they're
gonna trade them that we want to put him
in a spot because we like this guy where
we believe he's gonna thrive out of our
conference away from our division and
we're gonna put him in a spot where we
think that he's with good people who
give him a chance
look they could have trade him to
Cleveland since then Cleveland's fired
it's GM brought in a new GM questions
about the coach they weren't sending him
to a spot that they didn't trust in
their same conference let's send him out
west 3,000 miles away love John wins
great man
respect Kyle Shanahan great play caller
Jimmy's got a chance to survive and
thrive there and that's I think a big
part of it I think it was hand-picked
there you know what we like this spot
it's sort of like hitting a spot on the
map and I'm gonna go there and that's
how they did it they put the pin in the
map and said we're sending Jimmy here it
was even like San Francisco you know was
calling around to to get the guy loose
it was sort of like hey you just won a
million dollars you want to claim it
yeah send it our way
give me a wild-card coaching him give me
give me a name out of left field that
nobody's thinking about talking about
well the more of a Lewis name I gave
that to you because nobody's talking
about him and I think he figures into
this carousel everybody's waiting for a
decision in Cincinnati and I guess
that's fair because they have to figure
out whether he is indeed going to be
moving on from there or whether they
could work something out but the fact of
the matter is to think that Marvin
wouldn't be entertaining other ideas and
other options at this point in time I
think would be naive yeah but he's
talked about being a GM he's talking
about being a broadcaster I don't know
if his I don't know if his heart sounds
like it's in it to coach anymore
oh I think I think it's an I think it's
in there too - coach it's just a
question of what the opportunity and
what the situation is so to me that's
somebody that I think will be in the mix
the one that caught me by surprise
yesterday was the Patriots linebackers
coach getting a call to interview for
the job Brian Flores like you know we've
heard about Josh McDaniels referred by
Matt Patricia was anybody talking about
Brian Flores getting interviews and the
significance of that is if Matt Patricia
leaves and I believe he will then Brian
Flores I would have thought would have
been a prime candidate to succeed him
and now he's already getting interviews
which tells you that even if he doesn't
get a job this year maybe next year he's
he's a guy that we're talking about in
the same way that we're talking about
Steve Wilks or Matt Patricia or Josh
McDaniels this year hey have fun this
weekend your your Roman the sidelines is
that what you're gonna be doing yeah Dan
listen I thought we were going to
Jacksonville like they you know they
they they love to give us you know the
clients sleepy place on a Saturday
afternoon the first time slot as you
know and so I was all ready for
Jacksonville and even like where we're
going to Kansas City you know I've been
to Kansas City I can't work Denver for
15 years and I would go to Arrowhead
every December it seemed like and there
were years when I where there was 35
below and I thought well we're going to
Kansas City instead of Jacksonville Wow
okay nice let's change this have fun
Thank You Adam happy to YouTube on Adam
Schefter he's covering the Titans in
Kansas City and the mothership has
wildcard Saturday their coverage begins
at 4:20 s turn for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you